good morning everyone and i appreciate
you all
getting up early and welcome to the uh
wolfram technology conference um
as i said this is a new way of
presenting but it
might be a modern way and it has
obviously has certain advantages though
it's nice to see people and
talk in person um right let's just get
started
this talk is about the war from compiler
and i want to talk about things such as
the
um its operation and and its benefits
um some of the strategic goals and
some of the latest advantages
latest advances now there's a bunch of
related talks to the um compiler so
there's this talk that i'm giving now
a bit later this morning actually i
think sorry i got that wrong
that's good to have a live talk i can
fix it um
max fronyu is giving a talk at um 9
cst um that's cover
covering um optimizing code
and some of the arithmetic features that
i think will be
interesting and that's going to be
followed by a q a
session um that'll be like a sort of
live chat room type of thing and
we'll be there answering questions about
that and then
tomorrow morning i'm going to give
another talk that tries to focus on some
of the
high performance computing features in
the
compiler so right so what is the
compiler it's
it's a compiler for the wolfram language
and it's a long-term project i've been
giving presentations about this
for quite a few conferences some of you
might might remember
um it's something that's entirely built
in the wall from language so it's now
one of the largest
complete applications in in in wolfram
language
it's based upon the very latest
knowledge and technology
about compilers so the first version was
released in mathematica 12.
there was an update in 12.1 and we're
just coming up to a new update with 12.2
so the idea of the compiler
is it converts wolfram language
code into native machine code
so that code that runs very close
to the you know the the metal
the hardware of your machine it uses a
thing called llvm as the back end
i'm not going to talk a whole lot about
llvm it's it's a bit technical
it has a couple of modes of operating it
has like
an in-memory jit version so that's
that's very convenient for sort of
interactive use that fits with the
wolfram language the mathematica you
know
eval print loop um but it can also make
dynamic libraries that's that's useful
as well it's based upon
static type annotations but a minimal
set of static type annotations
combined with an inferencing technology
and you can think of it as an
alternative execution model
for the wolfram language it it
integrates
very well with the wolfram language
interpreter um
but it can also make standalone
applications as well
now what are some of the benefits of a
compiler
so it the the main one this is the thing
that everybody's interested in
is you get faster faster execution
so there's you know your code can run a
lot faster
since it knows about the hardware and
it's
you know able to figure out a whole load
of things ahead of time
in order to target specific machine
technology you get a guarantee of
correctness
this can be frustrating because you know
often it
takes a bit of time to get your program
to compile and such like
but when it does you've got quite a good
certainty
it's going to do what you want um it
fits with other cogeneration
systems and it can leverage it's a great
way of leveraging technology that's hard
to access in other ways and this is one
summary that i like to think of it is it
takes a high-level language
specification
the wolfram language and it combines
that with
low-level ie fast execution technology
so what is not the compile what if the
compiler is not
and you know this is source of
frustration to people
and such like it's not a magic solution
the way you wave
a magic wand and somehow everything gets
gets better
or at least it's not that it's not yet
reached that so um
i just want to try and thread through
some of the
directions some of why what we're doing
and what
you know the purpose of the individual
projects and such like
so so one goal we have is obviously to
compile wolfram
code to do that we have to increase the
set of functions that we're supporting
and to do that we often have to add new
types and i'll be showing some examples
of
what we do with this we want to generate
fast code so we have like this base
thing based on
generating machine code um but we've
we've done a lot of work
so we've been building up this library
of of things that
that actually mark's going to be talking
about um
we add various special optimizations and
we can access
hpc features that's going to be the
focus of my talk tomorrow um
we can support new directions
in the system new directions so we built
a data structure library we have tools
for
automatic differentiation some of these
hpc things
standalone applications so these are
really quite new
directions for the for the wall from
language
we can also enhance the existing system
so it's just a
a new implementation layer for the wall
from language that might
might interest people all from research
or outside of or from research
so another big goal that we have and
this is
something that's you know negative
you know not not a strong feature at the
moment is the compiler is
slow to generate code it's slow to run
the code it produces is fast but it's
slow
to run um
sorry i'm getting a message from someone
can someone else fix i'm speaking can
someone else fix my name in zoom
sorry um yes right
and so
just to rewind to this the solution that
we have the ultimate solution to improve
speed of compilation
is to compile the compiler
right um another thing that
i think of as quite interesting i'm
quite interested in computer science
aspects especially compilers i've been
working
implementing language and other computer
language you know
languages for many years but actually
it's a good demonstration the wall from
compiler and the wolfram system
is a good demonstration of why it's a
great environment for studying compilers
for doing research and development in
compilers i.e making new techniques
so those are some of the goals that are
going to thread through the
talk so i'm here i'm just now going to
give you a
basic demo so we we take a function
and it has these type annotations so
it's
just a regular mathematica wolfram
language function
but i've said that the two arguments
have are 64-bit integers
and i compile it with a thing called
function compile
and i get out the um you know
it executes now the original function
also compiles
or also executes so this one
but they're taking different paths the
uncompiled one
is going through the standard
interpreter this one is using this
compiled code function and is using
native machine code to execute results
are kind of the same
now in the compiler these are some
things that are
a bit different so we support a lot of
types
and for example we support um
what you might consider as a byte so an
eight bit
integer and again we we give markup
saying what the input is
it's still the same function plus but
now it's
going to select a version of plus that
is for
um you know eight bit
integers we also support half precision
floats
so these are real 16 so this is
quart the typical double precision
floating point that
that mathematica uses 64 bits this is a
quarter of that
and why do you care about these well
actually there's a lot of
application areas in machine learning or
image processing
where they actually need these sorts of
things because they're
use less memory so so you've got big
data sets you've got
images and things like that and you
don't need the full
range of the sizes that that you have
from um the uh
the full range of uh sizes sorry the ice
cream van is just derived that at people
from
you know the office here maybe you can
hear it
right um for each
of these types we so we've got we can
mix things up
um so we've got different integer types
and i'm doing a bit and
and things things all work and the
benefit of this
is that you know it's no use having all
these different types
if they're not fully supported so
that's that's true now another big area
of
functionality is array computation so
[Music]
well from language has long long had a
thing called pact arrays
so they look at that you know they
they're sort of
you know compatible with lists of
numbers
and so we have very good support of of
compiling code with with with packed
arrays so you say it's a patch array
of machine integer and it's that's the
number of indices so this is a vector
so um now what's kind of new
that that we have is we also have in the
system these things called numeric
arrays
these also hold scalar types they're
somewhat similar to packed arrays
but we have the same support for
functional constructs that we have with
pact arrays
and actually i'll just say that the
implementation of these
is you know we can share the
implementation so these
arrays pack to raise numeric arrays
these are a core way
that data is used in the wolfram
language so supporting those in
compilers
very useful here's another key thing
of the wolf language is that it's a
functional language
so we can have um you know nested
functions and do things with them
and this is kind of a it's now a pretty
standard
many languages have have these um you
know support support such things
and here i've written uh um you know
a recursive thing the only type
annotation i gave was was on the input
and it can figure everything out
um inside of this again
the the uncompiled version
and this is quite nice because i can
develop things
code uncompiled way when it's working
nice i
i can compile it for for a speed
enhancement that's
that's quite a good um work and then
moving along with the support of
functions you can get all these tangled
you know so here i've got one function
and i'm passing it as an argument to
another function and invoking it
and these things work um and
same thing i've got a function here and
this returns a function
and these sorts of things all work now
these are rather tangled ways of adding
you know incrementing an argument but
actually
they're they they can you know they they
can be quite quite
quite important um
another key feature of
the um
compiler is to get compilation errors
i'm seeing a few questions i'm probably
going to answer some of the questions
towards the end
unless they're totally um
related to the um the you know the
thing that i'm showing at the moment um
so here what i have
is i've got i've got a program a
function
and i've got a boolean here
and in one of the branches so i'm doing
a condition one of the branches i'm
initializing it
and then i'm returning it and the
compiler comes up with
an error message sorry i'm just taking a
getting a bit dry and
there's probably some error in your code
or here's another one so i'm i'm
invoking the sine function on a boolean
and it doesn't know what what the
boolean is this is probably
very likely an error and so this is
pointing to a new way to find unintended
code
from static analysis not from running it
so it doesn't matter if this if this
thing here
was was reached or not reached um it's
it's you know it gives an error and you
can go and
consider fixing your fixing your code
we also have a bunch of um runtime
errors
and so here's an example of such a thing
so
the arithmetic system is validated i've
got an integer 64
and assigned integer 64. so this is the
largest
input that i can have and if we
go one higher we get an error now
the default value of the version of
function compile
is that it restarts the computation
in in in the evaluator so that's that's
why this thing comes back now you can
actually
disable there's there's techniques to
disable this
so if i do this in an unchecked block
then i get the you know the result that
you would expect here
but now it stays as a
integer 64 but it's it's wrapped around
because it's using
you know the modular two's complement um
arithmetic system and so that might be
an unintended um
thing but actually being able to either
catch these errors or not
care about them is quite important and
and actually when you seamlessly switch
under the hood from you know sort of
machine integers to software integers
or to symbolic forms this is often
a key source of slowness when people
show me their code and how can they make
it faster
very often that they're making big
symbolic things in the middle
and being able to detect these is or or
you can get rid of them
is quite useful right
saving to a library so here i've got
a bigger you don't have to read all of
this but this is an implementation
of a quick sort function so i'm taking
a packed array and i'm compiling it
into a library and then
i can load the library
and it just load the library and it
returns a compiled code function
and then i apply it to a bunch of things
and it's it's sorting the code
so this sorting actually runs runs
pretty fast it's not quite as fast as
the built-in
um sort which actually uses parallel
techniques for um
you know divides things up and runs them
all in in parallel and then recombines
them
um but but for such a simple
specification of quicksort
it's it's pretty fast actually
and the big benefit of saving the
library is you
don't have to recompile things all the
time you can just
you can just load things um after the
fact
now here are some some new things that
we're going to talk about
so as we want to support more
functionality
we're going to need more um more types
and so this this thing here this is one
that
not totally optimized for compilation
speed
it's a little bit slow it should come
back eventually
and there we go and
quite this slow there we go fine
so what i've here is i've got a string
and i'm putting it into
a list and i'm doing a string join and
the
thing so when we look at this actual
compiled code function
what we've got coming back is a thing
called the list array
so this is a list array of strings so we
saw
pact arrays and numeric arrays this is
something we call
a lister listerine this is something
that can contain anything
so here's another aspect of list array
is that it can work for ragged
data so there we
go and so so here i've given a list
array
that itself contains a list array of
integers
now with if i was using the standard
array technologies packed array numeric
array
then they only contain a fixed set of
numerical contents
and they must be rectangular so this
list array
is can contain anything it's not only
scalar types
and they do not nest you know compound
things
do not need to be rectangular so it's
closer
to the wall from motion of a list so
this this is pretty useful
right now i'm going to
um talk now about
some of the you know generating fast
code the
fast to execute i'll probably talk a
little bit about this at the end if i've
got time
it's a bit hard to gauge the the
the usage of time that that i'm working
through and i
don't think i'm doing too badly so um
one of the ways that we've worked is
we've been this is a big thing that's
been worked on
particularly by marks fonu in the last
in this version they're about to release
is a subsystem
for arithmetic and this is the
benefit of this is so we've implemented
arithmetic functions
and these are things that most of you
we'll we'll just imagine you do
you know x plus y or or more
you know mordor and you know sign or
something and you just
take it for granted that these things
work but but actually
it's it's tremendous you know it's it's
not trivial to make this
this all work in a consistent fashion um
the big advantage of implementing all
this in the compiler is
that it all gets inlined into one
functions
and since the arithmetic is kind of fast
to execute anyway
lifting it out from individual function
calls
is is a tremendous um you know sort of
has a lot of speed advantages um mark's
giving a talk about this a bit later
today
right um so
um the compiler is great technology for
adding
you know fundamentally new technology to
the wolfram language
um and some of these such as the
multi-core parallelism
i'll be talking about in the hbc
talk that i'm doing later now one new
feature
that we did add we started in 12.1 is
and it's extended in 12.2 is a library
of data structures so these are these
are built
these are coded up in the compiler and
then we pre-compile them
into a library so that you don't have to
run the compiler in order to
create them and another key thing is
some of the data structures
are mutable so
just list some of what what we've got
we've got some
core things like a counter and and a
value
we have a whole load of container
data structures so this is an extensible
array or a linked list or
queues and stacks and buffers and things
like that
we have a bunch of sets so bit vector
um you know various
hash sets disjoint sets sorted multiset
we now we tend to add them when other
parts of the company need
you know development need a data
structure we can add them
we've got various this is a binary tree
this is a balanced
binary tree using avl balancing
and this is a general tree and then we
have some
key store key value store data
structures so let's just have a quick
so this is using the the the
wolfram interpreter so i can create an
instance of like this is an
avl tree and then i can go and insert
a bunch of you know things into the
the tree so one of the nice things about
this avial tree is it balances things so
actually you can see
i mean it's not optimally balanced
because you could probably put this you
know these these things down here
but it never gets worse than um
this this sort of i'm balancing it's
kind of the guarantee of the
the algorithm and so one of the nice
things about these
data structures is that you can do
computations on them so
so sort of you know this is one here
where i'm
i want to you know figure out what's the
maximum depth
so i i can write a little bit of code
like that and then
and then run this maximum depth thing
and i can see the maximum depth is six
so that means the longest path
from the root is is six which which
actually looks
looks feasible so what's new
in 12.2 is to add more seamless
integration between uncompiled and
compiled code
so here for example i've got a um
i've written some code that i could
write so this is a
function that takes a dynamic array and
it's
it's reversing so there's like a swap
part
um operation of of dynamic array and
it's
it's reversed the thing here and so it's
taken these
you know and see that it's it's reversed
so
so what's quite nice is i can take
exactly the same code
and i can um compile it and so now
it's reversing it since this is done
mutability
in place then then you know it's just
turned it back to where it was
in the beginning so what's quite nice
about this is if i make
a large this is like 10 million data
structures
if we've got quite a good acceleration
so this is the
uncompiled reverse function
and it runs six seconds
the compiled version is running nearly
100 times faster
so this is some of giving some idea of
some of the benefits
of the um um
that you can get from uh compiling
things quite quite significant speed ups
but what what we kind of like is
you know it's the same function we you
can develop the function
test it out and debug it and you know
prototype it
in uncompiled way and then compile it
and then you could even save it a
library or something
so
i'll probably go back to some of the
data structures and show some of these
when i talk about some of the
type system i think i'm not doing too
bad with
time um so there's a set of compiler
definitions that we write and then we
built a data structure library from them
um but there's lots more functions for
like sorting or traversing
and if something's not built in it's
easy to add
and then if it's compiled it's just as
fast
as if we wrote it and again that's one
of the things that's always
you know goal of the project is that
you know there's always an impediment
for
users working in in the city you know
they have to wait for us to go and add
things
internally in the system with the
compiler
that barrier is is broken down and it's
quite feasible to write things
in the same way that we write them but
they're just
just as fast so i think that's that's
that's
you know advantageous at some some cost
so again another of the goals was to
support
existing um
functionality um and by the way there's
a question about how do you know whether
the
data structure can be placed changed in
place or not
the documentation says whether they're
mutable or or
or not um that's that's part of the
you know documentation um so supporting
areas such as machine learning or
numerical computation
um we've looked at you supporting the
cloud
um notebook system with generating web
assembly
um but there's still a constraint on
this is that the compiler is still very
slow to run so that that is a constraint
now i want to talk about another thing
that i think is quite
quite interesting um this might be
interesting to people who are familiar
with other compilers
but you know a thing that's
an important feature of the wolfram
compiler is that it sits
it's integrated into an existing
language and that gives advantages and
disadvantages
so so one thing it means is that the
semantics
of the language the way that plus and
times and fold
and you know module are
fixed you know we we don't have a choice
as to how they
they should work um it also means that
since the existing system
is um
you know a sort of interpreted system
there's a lot of code that at the
outside looks as though it can be
ambiguous and and so we've developed
ways of dealing with that that i think
are quite interesting
and then finally a huge advantage is
that the compiler can make use
of the wolfram language environment in
in which it lives
and and there are some lots lots of neat
ways benefits of that
and that's that's quite unique in terms
of um
compiled um systems so here's one
i'll just sort of compile these i've got
two programs here and
i want to focus on this thing here so
in
in this one here f is
a function see there's f there's a
function there
and i'm giving the function a string as
an argument
but in this other one here f is a a data
structure
and here i'm calling an operation like
like a method call
on the data structure so
but the syntax we don't have a special
syntax for that we're just using
and this is you know like like
associations have
you know you you can do lookup in an
association based upon these
these sort of sub-value things so in the
interpreter of course it's easy because
it knows
oh yes this is this thing and it can
decide what to do
now it's actually
quite non-trivial and we we had to build
in this is another new thing in the new
version
is to develop the technology to um
be able to disambiguate based upon the
context so
when it sees something like this it has
to say well
it has to spawn off alternatives in in
the analysis
and then bring them to to completion but
but we did that and so when we compile
this one here it it's able to um
get one answer and you know so it deals
with this correctly
and this is something that in in
languages
like the wolfram language there are many
things like that
and having a an underlying compiler
that's able to that
is super useful it means that
you know ultimately as we we build this
up we'll
have more ability to compile more of the
language
many other things that we um you know
this is a feature of the type system
obviously there are many things as as we
build up that that are going to be
challenged um challenging but
having this underlying ability to
disambiguate what
in essence looks like ambiguous
syntax is is is super useful
now here's another nice way that we use
the wolfram language we use the
visualization features
this is a bit more something that would
be useful for people
developing um you know
developing compilers or something so
i've just loaded a little thing for
graph tools um so here i've got a
function
and what does it do it's got like a
branch
and then there's a loop and it returns a
result
and we can look at this is the sort of
intermediate code
that that's that's generated so this is
the you know
dealing with the exception from from
overflows but there's a bunch of
branches and things
but it's a bit hard to sort of see all
of that
but what's quite nice is to then come
and get
a control flow graph so this is just
the control flow in one function so
here's
here's the start and you can see and
this is the
the end so every every arrow
you know ultimately ends up up here and
actually looking at this more abstracted
view of the code
is is is is really useful i mean this is
something that we really use quite
quite you know you you use an awful lot
but this is making you know we've got
all this other stuff in the wall from
language
so we're able to use that in order to
develop
the the compiler and and to enhance and
gain
insight and knowledge and this makes you
know our compiler
the war from system is is is pretty
useful for learning
about compilers and developing them
here's another way seemingly
trivial but i can use the
outer the you know right programs in
you know uncompiled scripted programs to
build up
or from you know a set of a set of
functions
so here i'm just you know iterating over
and i've made a
bunch of um you know one bunch of bunch
of functions
and we use this a ton when we're setting
setting the system up and i know this
so so we're using the rapid prototyping
system to create things
and doing this in other systems i know
is
astonishingly painful you know
it's it's you know and yet it's so
natural
in in wolfram language so that's that's
that's
that's kind of a nice um feature
here's another feature that we can do is
we want to prepare data at compilation
time
so here what i'm doing is i want to
write
a function to test if
numbers are prime numbers and so one way
i can do this is i could make
a um just um
i can make a lookup table so here i've
made lookup table
and i'm saying you know is is the thing
a prime number
or or or is it not and then i've
compiled this
and so this says you know six is not
prime but seven is so i can do like a
test here
so so i've been able to prepare data
before and then sort of injected that
data
inside the body of the function so
that's
that's that's pretty useful now
in essence actually just to go a little
bit further um
there's a lot of redundancy in this so
we can do much better than this so first
of all this table here
i'm using you know like like machine
integers
to hold all this data but really there's
just
it's just one bit that's that's needed
and secondly
so there's a couple of tricks that you
can use so you can avoid the even
numbers since it's very there's a very
quick
test um and then you can pack everything
down
to to one bit so we can make a table
that looks like this now this table is
completely
unintelligible you know if i did b 32
comma
you know three or something so i just
got these big uh
um um um
tables and things um and
then we have to do like reverse so we
did
compression of the the numbers down into
bits
and then when we run the test so first
of all we check if the
the input's divisible by two in which
case we return false
and then the next thing we do is to
do the bit shifting and then we look it
up and if we've
found something then it's and so we can
we can run this and you know
seven is prime and so what's nice about
this is when we compare this
with the built-in um sometimes you have
to like let these things warm up a bit
um it's pretty competitive
with the built-in and this one actually
beats the the built-in prime though
i would strongly suspect most of the
time here is spent in the overhead of
accessing the the code so if you were
integrating this prime queue into your
own code
that that then it would really start to
be very
um efficient so just to go back to this
you know again doing this you know
making these tables of data and stuff
in other systems is you know very
painful and prone to error and
um a source of bugs you know i think the
famous intel
um the famous intel
division era from way back maybe some of
you don't remember this because
it was but that was caused exactly by an
error
in a lookup table that was used to um
you know first for some code and the
closer you can have
generation of this data you you could
even build some verification
you know into the compilation or
something that that that might be useful
um the closer your data generation is to
it to its
you know sort of applicability then then
that's that's going to help
avoid errors right
so um let's come and have a look at um
the
integrating with external code
and so this is something that we we do a
lot to sort of build out
um um existing functionality
so some of these things
you know they're not specified in a
completely
convenient way but um so here i'm
calling into the c
library on my system and there's a thing
there's a function there that is
um gets the time in in
in in seconds so so what i've done here
is i've added a declaration i've added a
declaration of a new function
where the it's linked to an external
library
and the name in the external library is
time and i've given it a different name
here
and here's the type of the function
and so now i can invoke this
you know and i get a different different
answer each time
now this is kind of a trivial sort of
thing actually i did just add another
example with a
um this is another function that takes a
um takes
a you know result of seconds and it
returns a string
formatting of the of the result
so this is just so i'm just calling the
the you know functionality that's
elsewhere on my system
um and and it's rel it's
pretty pretty easy so just the
specification of these things
you know that's not completely smooth
yet but the
the concepts very powerful so we we
build a lot of extensions to
integrate with existing libraries um and
then we've this this is how we've been
building
omp or or or integrations into other
other libraries that we can do in this
way so it's fairly straightforward
so we just build a big big load of these
you know declarations like this
and then we can start to access them
from from the
compiler um
right so now i want to talk about the
um type system um
so the idea we have a type inferencing
system we have sort of minimal markup
um we support what we call
paramet polymorphic definitions so a
little bit of code
can go a long way and we can create new
types
we have a way of creating structures um
but not a union type and that's maybe
you're not
um and then we also support function
overloading and it has a
good way to choose between um
choices and i'm going to give some some
demonstration of this
so now i'm going to declare a function
and this
this is the name of the function and
it's declared for
one one type so there's only a version
of this function
that takes an integer 64. and that's
that's that's all it does
now i'm going to make a polymorphic
version of the function
so this thing here takes any any input
so it returns the same result the
previous one also returned
a a string but this one here is a
has takes any input um
and that's but it returns a different
value it's it's still a string and so we
i need to there we go you see it didn't
find that but now it compiles
and and and runs so i got that that sort
of warning saying i haven't
declared it we can even in fact go
a bit more and we can give a constraint
on the
um type so now i'm saying here's another
version
of this test function that is defined
for um if if the element is
is known to be an you know a number and
so
so now i have three different versions
of this
and all of the choices as to what things
that's all done
at compile time so it's it's it's
it's it's all very fast um
but you know and even if i went back and
recompiled this thing here
it it still works so this selection of
different types
is um you know it's set up to choose the
narrowest type so
so since there's a version for integer
it chooses
that um when it's a real 64 it knows
that that's an element
of that so it chooses that and then the
boolean case
was no constraints it chose that and so
it's
and this is again something that we put
a lot of work on
into the um
um you know latest version um
but um that's
you know you know good good good good
benefit and having
the thing be sort of deterministic and
able to work is
is is pretty useful
so going back to the data structures um
another feature of the data structures
is that they
are or many of them it
varies um but um are especially
a polymorphic so so here's a data
structure
and you can see here so i've given a
dynamic array
and i'm appending a real 64
to the dynamic array and it
and then i'm returning that and so the
type system it's figured out that this
is a dynamic array
that contains real 64. but if i had a
slightly different code
and the thing that was being appended
was a string
but now i have a dynamic array of
strings and then
if there's no way of figuring this out
so here i've got a function
that a dynamic array where
there's no way of understanding what the
figure determining what
the argument is so it has a default
value which is expression
so that's that's that's that's what we
have here
and the benefit about this is that it
means that you get fast efficient code
when you
write compile code with these data
structures it's it's quite feasible to
be
polymorphic and again this helps to go
from
uncompiled to compile code
another um this is something that
lives in compile code
[Music]
is we have a an iterator system and then
we can use the
iterators this is a little bit slow to
compile
but we use these iterators to
um get this up
so here i've got a do loop and i'm so
this is similar there's
other things if this was a list or
something it would it would also work
but element is lm is being bound to each
member of the um dynamic array
and this is all built on we we have a a
nice library of
of iterators except we you we call that
generically from the um um
you know from from from from the
implementation of do loop
but again this is all if it's known that
there's an iterator then this this sort
of thing will
will compile and um
that's kind of the the same thing so
there's a lot of
extra functionality of these um
data structures and you know this is
with this iterated thing you you can
write quite
um general code where it just has to
know that it has access
to these these various um iterators
right so the compiler
is very slow to run um
and the solution for that is to compile
the compiler which which we're working
on very
actively to do this week there's some
more compiler functionality that needs
to be builded out
but the key thing is to tackle more wall
from language
um definitions um
specifications and that's the notion of
down values now i'll
show that in a minute but but one thing
that we have done
is to start building libraries of common
operations
so so this is a trade-off between
it makes compilation faster
but it can hurt execution speed because
the code in a library
can't can't be inlined so this is a
trade between
compilation time and and run time but
some of these things that don't in line
so much it's not so important for
example our string operations
and we've built a library of um
string operations so here i've run a
compilation
of of string join and this is just
calling the gonna call the version of
string join
from the library but if i compare this
with another
um so i'm creating a type environment
and i'm saying don't don't load any
libraries
into this so now there's there's lots of
code now this might seem
a lot of code but of course each one of
these lines is like
one one machine instruction on your cpu
so so it's you know not not super fast
um so this is a way that we can speed up
compilation by making a trade-off with
with execution speed
and that's that's that's something that
i think you know is
can be kind of useful right
now let's come and look at some more um
more code so here's um
some description about
down value compilation so basically i
want to compile
functions that are written with patterns
and set delayed
i want to write my code like that you
can
benefit from the compiler maybe there's
type annotations maybe there are not
and we've been working on this it's not
by any means a complete
finished system
but there are some um benefits
so so here i've i've written the thing
and then i do
compile values and now when we enter
something it goes and looks for a
compiled version and then and then it
generates it
if it's not available if it finds one
then
then it uses it so something that's
quite nice is that if i have other
compiled code
and the other compiled code might itself
be embedded
in a down value then it makes use of of
this system
so it makes this is accessible and so
now
i'm i've got a compiled
i've got a function and it's calling the
f that that i just compiled
and so when i generate the machine code
for this
it it can make use of the um
function that i already pre-compiled and
then this
this sort of runs and that's that's
i mean this this all seems sort of you
know
natural but this is the way to to to to
make
these things faster and here's another a
variant where i've actually given a type
annotation so it
figures out from the pattern um
and i'm going to compile this and
then when i run this so
so one of the things that's quite nice
about this is this
i saw this it's so i've written
the you know
typical program and then i did
you know compile values and
it got a lot faster and just out of to
compare
here's the um uncompiled version
so we're getting quite good you know
quite good speed ups
so this is to me this is kind of the
holy grail
of you know writing code and then just
having very minimal
access to to compile it and getting a
benefit
and so this is this is quite close to
the magic that
that i talked to this is not a
um the final a final sort of
thing though so um right
but so this is not
you know a ready thing this this is sort
of a future thing
but um when we can have this natural
integration of down values of the
compiler
that then we can get you know very
significant speed enhancements
in the code right
i don't have a lot of time left but i'll
just finally look at some
ways that we work to optimize code
rewriting it and to be faster or maybe
if you're willing to
relax some of the
input arguments and some of the benefits
so
just a quick down the sort of pipeline
that we go through so we have
start with the wolfram language program
we convert it into this
intermediate representation we convert
it in
we give it type analysis
and then we generate this thing called
llvm
and then lvm generates machine code so
we have various transformations and
optimizations in the wolfram stage
but then there's further transformations
and optimizations with
llvm and one thing we do a lot of work
at is to make sure that we're able to
leverage the llvm optimizations
as much as we can so first here's
something that i'm going to do with
um showing
just a code pattern so so these two
code functions do the same thing this
one is using a
functional construct and this is doing
the same thing but it's doing
a do loop and
i'm going to so then you have to say are
you paying a price
for this either in compiled code or
i mean this is what it does it's sort of
just sort of adding up all the
all the elements so let's compare
the speed of execution and i'm going to
give you know 100 million
inputs and
so we get the same answer but the the
non-functional way
and and you can see similar things in
um wolfram code so
so one thing that we've done oh and
here's just like a comparison
um and actually i see there's some
discussion of the old compiler
this this is actually using the old
compiler so
for this particular thing the the old
compiler is like
10 times slower than the new one and
even even worse compared with the um
you know the sort of non-functional
thing so
we added some special you know another
optimization level
and this is what comes out of this
so we compiled those
and now the
the actual the functional version
has got you know jumping around a bit
this is the the functional
thing that's written with fold that's
the code you want to write because it's
more concise and you don't have to worry
about the details of how the things done
is actually faster than the um
and that's that's the various reasons we
we then inlined
various you know i won't go into all the
details but we've
we're able to sort of basically turn
this into
you know there's much more inlining and
since there's more knowledge about
it's a high level description it
actually ends up with faster code
and that's that's kind of the value
proposition of functional
um programming so with the right
optimization
system the functional is is actually
winning out and it's much better to
write
so here's another um lower level
optimization this is talking about
um loop optimizations so again i've got
some
some code there's a loop here and
we do repeated timing and this runs
at a certain speed so we can do some
things
we can relax some things so if i turn
off the abort handling
then i make something that you know you
can't hit control c
or interrupt the code but
but it's actually makes makes the thing
run faster
and here's another thing i can do
use an unchecked block so this is the
arithmetic here
is is running you know sort of
unchecked and this is also so this is
faster you know both of these are about
twice as fast
now then if you combine these then
i'm going to do the unchecked version
and turn off abort handling
then it actually runs astonishingly fast
in fact
it's running independently of the length
because
this loop here is what's known as an
afine loop
and so it can just you know replace that
loop
with the um you know formula for the
for the result so this you know it's
going to be
you know sort of you know the speed is
independent of the length of the loop
which which is quite nice and this is
just showing that
you know there are there are
optimizations this is making use of some
of the llvm
optimizations but there's there's a
variety of technologies and
optimizations to work with um
there's lots more code optimizations
that we we could be doing
right fine just coming up to finish uh
running off
time so speed of compilation current
directions
needs to be much faster um we need to
add union types
i think now we're getting a system
that's quite um
quite quite you know powerful we do have
this
um
manual documentation one of the nice
things that we've
added we have you know things like
look up functions and
so this like copy to and
it has nice ways to jump off to the um
input documentation um to show you the
implementation integrating down values
parallel constructs
they're in development development tools
and and more optimization
so i'm going to um end my talk
so i was showing some of the goals and
benefits and progress
of the warfarin compiler um
i was demonstrating some of the core
functionality
with types and things in the data
structure library
some of the ways that it integrates with
the rest of the system
looked at the type system and some of
the newer advanced features
and these are some of the other talks um
and finally i'll just have a good thing
we have a lot of opportunities in the
company for developers or interns
working on the compiler it's it's
detailed for some but for some
people it's completely fascinating um
and there's lots of
projects interesting new technologies
building out the current features and
developing new compiler text so get in
contact with the
company and uh come and come and join in
if
if this is interesting to you anyway i
think
i'm about to
um wrap up i've got a few questions here
now this is somewhere i'm just about out
i don't know if everybody has to go
off to something i can also answer some
of these questions
um at uh you know at the
there's a q a session a bit later this
morning
um so i'll just quickly answer well then
you see system replace library link
um i think it's sort of orthogonal to to
to to to library link um but but
and it needs needs some build out so um
the um okay i'll i'll try
whoops sorry i'll try to thanks thanks
phil
um i'll i'll try to um
um share the notebook um the
some of these things are in 12.1 some of
them will be in 12.2 and some of them
are going to be
sort of future things um the speed of
the compiler
the old compiler is is is useful um
but i think the new one now especially
in 12.2 is
is predominantly faster but it has
tremendously more
functionality um you know
you know things like that there's the um
data structure and the documentation
says whether things are mutable we've
actually started working this is not
ready yet on some
immutable data structures like immutable
um arrays and immutable sets and of
course that's what
association is so we'd like to have an
implementation that but the
top-level feature association is an
immutable
um hash table um
data structures are useful there's some
questions
about um gpus
i think i'll study those i'm not going
to quickly answer that though there's no
gpu
there's no nvidia functionality for
apple that doesn't exist that's you
should use linux or
um windows machines
anyway i think i'll wrap up and uh thank
you
very much everybody great okay yeah
compile values
phil is not in 12.2 i'm afraid that's
but that's obviously an important
feature to moving anyway thank you very
much thank you
you